you're watching the askgaryvee show can  somebody play some music with all due  respect to my fans I don't want it yes  that's not a good thing to do this is  quite simple I'm given to be sent to  your mother don't be a looker are you  willing to make the commitment to  allocate dollars into humans this is  like a humble brag question it just  comes down to what are you good at this  is a big unknown thing to a lot of  people I am so flabbergasted  the answer is gosh [ __ ] I don't know I  mean you can crush it doing video  blogging thank you I'm getting very you  to be pink  Gary honey I like it anyway you with a  little bit wait I was about to close but  the question of the day say little rusty  from all that kind of like they came  that was me looking at my tan if you  were wondering what the hell that was  question of the day what is your  favorite episode of the askgaryvee show  you with a little bit of me we're  changing the QA world whether they like  it or not